how to batch
inputs together in this video we'll see
how to batch input sequences together
in general the sentences we want to pass
through our model won't all have the
same length
here we are using the model we saw in
the sentiment analysis pipeline
and want to classify two sentences when
tokenizing them
and mapping each token to its
corresponding input ids
we get two lists of different lengths
trying to create a tensor on a buy array
from those two lists
will result in an error because all
arrays and answers
should be rectangular one way to
overcome this limit is to make the
second sentence the same length as the
first
by adding a special token as many times
as necessary
another way would be to truncate the
first sequence to the length of the
second
but we would then lose a lot of
information that might be necessary to
properly classify the sentence
in general we only truncate sentences
when they are longer than the maximum
length the model can handle
the value used to pass the second
sentence should not be picked randomly
the model has been retrained with a
certain padding id
which you can find in tokenizer.pat
doconate
now that we have padded our sentences we
can make a batch with them
we pass the two sentences to the model
separately and patched together however
we notice that we don't get the same
results for the sentence that is padded
here the second one hmm is that a bug in
the transformers library
no if you remember that transformers
will all make easy use of attention
layers
this should not come as a total surprise
when computing the contextual
representation of each token
the attention layers look at all the
other words in the sentence
if you have just a sentence or the
sentence with several paddy tokens added
is surgical we don't get the same values
to get the same results with or without
padding we need to indicate to the
attention layers
that we should ignore those padding
tokens this is done by creating an
attention mask
a tonsil with the same shape as the
input ids with zeros and ones
once indicate the tokens the attention
layers should consider in the context
and zeros the tokens we should ignore
now passing this attention mask along
with the input id
will give us the same results as when we
send the two sentences individually to
the model
this is all done behind the scenes by
the tokenizer when you apply it to
several sentences
with the flag padding equal to it will
apply this padding with a proper value
to the smaller sentences and create the
appropriate attention mask